um are women allowed to observe IA in
their houses as far as is concerned
according to the of the Quran of 2 ver7
which says that do not associate with
your wives and do retreat in the mosque
so since the word is specific the ruling
is in the mosque as it's a ruling for
the gens that they should do EA in the
mosque the same ruling applies even for
the woman there are a few Scholars who
do say thata can be done in the home
where the woman prays based on the
Hadith that praying in a room is better
than praying in the outer room in the
house praying in the house is better in
the courtyard in the courtyard better
than the mosque but this doesn't mean
Masjid literally means a place where you
do suud it's more of a word where you do
suud but technically the word Masid used
in Surah Bak chap 187 means a proper
Masjid not where you do suud because in
the Inner Room a person changes clothes
and a person in the state of jun
sexually Etc so the ruling for the women
as far as the major Scholars are
concerned if they want to do they should
do in the mosque and that's for
mentioned several Hadith including the
of bukari volume number three in the
book of Hadith number
2026 with that she says that the prophet
in the last 10 days of Ramadan and after
he died his wife continued with the
practice so the wife of the Prophet did
in the mosque and there's no evidence to
show that they were did in the house
okay good that's uh very good to know